could this be HBO's next Game of Thrones
it's possible the sci-fi reboot
Westworld makes its debut Sunday October
2nd and it looks extremely promising
let's take a look at the original movie
that inspired the 2016 show number one
West world was written and directed by
the brilliant Michael Crichton you know
the guy that would later give us
Jurassic Park ER and countless other
best-selling books he didn't just tell a
story he created massive worlds to be
explored
number two MGM only agreed to let
Crichton direct his movie if he could
stay within a 1.3 million dollar budget
that's not a lot of money even for 1973
an extremely challenging due to the
subject matter oh and the film had to be
shot in 30 days tops number three
Crichton visited Kennedy Space Station
where he observed how astronauts were
trained he was struck by how machine
like they were conditioned to make their
responses and even heartbeats as
predictable as possible he wondered what
consequences could occur if the
distinctions between man and machine
became blurred number four Westworld was
the first film to use cgi as a special
effect
Crichton wanted to show the point of
view of a robot so he reached out to Jet
Propulsion Laboratory they could process
two minutes of film for $200,000 it
would also take nine months what a deal
Crichton didn't have that time or money
so he asked experimental filmmaker John
Whitney jr. to create the sequence for
just $20,000 he finished it in four
months number five West world is also
the first movie to reference the idea of
a computer virus in the film they
actually refer to the computer
malfunction as an infection this is way
before we knew about trojans botnets and
scareware it wasn't until the early
1980s that the first actual computer
virus made headlines number six the
investment paid off West's world was
MGM's top grossing movie of 1973 earning
a respectable 10 million dollars in the
box office the success led to a sequel
future world but it was a cheap
imitation of the original and ended any
hopes of a film franchise another reboot
was attempted in 1980 with the
appropriately named TV series Beyond
West world
it began with Westworld three-to-one
activate so it lasted a mere three
episodes on air before being canceled
back now in 2016
HBO has assembled some of the top
Hollywood talent behind and in front of
the camera the JJ Abrams produced series
is written by Jonathan Nolan you know
him from inception in the dark night he
co-wrote those with his older brother
Christopher it stars Anthony Hopkins
Edie Harris and Evan Rachel Wood amongst
many many others earlier this year there
was some concern about production delays
but it turns out producers wanted to
firm up a plan for the next five or six
years not just the ten episodes we'll
see this season judging by their
commitment and the footage we've already
seen in the trailers it looks like it's
well worth your time as always for more
your favorite movies TV shows and comics
keep it here on gamespot universe are
you real well if you can't tell does it
matter
you